animators work entirely in two
dimensions taking an image that's flat
and inert and creating the illusion of
life something that was sadly never
achieved with al gore
the art of animation has come a long way
from the early days now instead of being
hunched over drawing tables creating
thousands of individual cells
animators are hunched over computer
keyboards creating thousands of
merchandising opportunities
but some things haven't changed the pink
panther still can't adopt in florida
the nominees are monsters incorporated
pete doctor and john lasseter
jimmy neutron boy genius steve odekirk
and john a davis
shrek aaron warner
gosh up until now i thought monsters
incorporated was a documentary on the
weinsteins
but oh
we kid the rich and powerful because we
love them the academy rules
specify that animated characters must
remain in their seats only real people
can accept the award
so please be animated and the oscar goes
to
shrek
this is the first academy award
nomination and the first oscar
for producer aaron warner shrek employs
state of the art cgi animation
producer jeffrey katzenberg said that it
will be a benchmark
for about a day or two
thank you members of the academy for
inviting us to the party
by creating this uh category to begin
with shrek took five years and over 500
people to bring to life
so i'm incredibly honored to be up here
on behalf of the entire team
a special thanks go to john williams who
originally brought
the book william steig's book to
dreamworks laurie mcdonald who thought
it might make a good animated movie
the amazing directors andrew adamson and
vicki jensen our incredible cast
mike myers eddie murphy cameron diaz and
john lithgow
executive producers penny fingerman cox
sandy raymonds and david littman
terry press and jim tharp at dreamworks
and the entire staff of animators and
artists
at pdi dreamworks finally i want to
thank my fellow producer jeffrey
katzenberg
who has a love for animation that
borders on obsession
and who is the real reason we're here
tonight thank you